c'est fou ce que je suis bon sens la
balle
tu la trouves comment la préfère déjà à
toi
on regarde ce que vous oubliez ça jimmy
fond de tana il mondo meilleur disque
jamais enregistré par un italien qui a
l'air d'avoir un animal mort sur la tête
tu es l'album
il a beau les bills
aux places que le match commence c'est
parti quelle rencontre extraordinaire
pour la première fois un père et son
fils s'affrontent en finale des mondiaux
de tennis de table et aucun des deux
n'est chinois c'est une partie d'en
faire ce livre le vétéran champion du
monde et son fils le premier pont gist
britannique ouvertement rouquin mais le
garçon a l'air sur le point de craquer
il a des larmes dans les yeux banide ou
pas bientôt en avoir